bring in Michael Irvin the playmaker and
Michael joins us tough Mike let me start
there the jumping over the offensive
line over the center to block the kick
as we saw with Denver in New Orleans do
you like that I don't know you know you
move the kickback you want to make it
more exciting uh we so can't chance to
do that and and now we're seeing guys do
that at crucial moments III don't know
how I feel about that Dan you know I
want you to be able to use your physical
gift athletic ability if you can jump
like that be able to jump like that but
but III just don't know I want to get a
chance to get that thing off arm all
right so so I'm kind of neutral on it
yeah I wonder if we'll see any kind of
rule changes in the offseason with it
you know the fact that we've moved it
back so there's more room for you to be
able to jump and the kick is going to be
at a lower angle but you know you do you
think the guys that came up with this
never thought that somebody dudes we
have this kind of leaving the pill if
they were like it it was almost like
they didn't think this could happen well
you know what I mean but Mike you're
gonna go to the combine and you're gonna
look for somebody who's got an
unbelievable vertical a special teams
guy and and just say all right you know
I I can I got a 42 inch vertical all
right you can jump over some offensive
lineman and that's a that's a great
weapon to have right in and think about
this now in certain situations like it
was yesterday who cares if you get the
penalty I'm gonna make you know it's a
game winner so who cares do you know
what I mean so it encourages you to keep
doing that and keep breaking the room
it's just it's just a bedroom in it let
me give him the official introduction
he's Michael Irvin NFL network analyst
Hall of Famer you can see Mike on sunday
NFL network NFL gameday morning starting
at nine a.m. eastern I the Cowboys MVP
is we're nervous you can see Mike
everywhere he's omnipresent the yard the
Cowboys MVP is
the league MVP d Chiarelli texas to and
i think so tired of us always going
through a quarterback for the MVP now
the sick thing that debt prescott
certainly deserves an honor like rookie
of the year but that Prescott is great
that he's been playing would not be
doing the things he's doing without is
video Elliott and that's not a knock on
that Prescott I mean the only
quarterback again win without a good
running game in this NFL is Tom Brady
every other quarterback we talked about
you eating that kind of support so I
don't understand why when it comes to
MVP voting for the league we discount
the very thing that we say these
quarterbacks me the most well they need
a great offensive line so we're
discounting the Cowboys offensive line
which to me is the MVP for the Cowboys
this year well but now listen let me see
it through this way that offensive line
at MVP you just call was here last year
they look like an MVP you know what I
mean not that they're not a great
offensive line they are that but it must
be the merits in the commingling of
Goodman Mike but like who is running the
football last year and who was throwing
the football last year for Dallas so you
can be a great offensive line I still
have to have people who are in place who
are capable of doing it but you can it's
rare to have it the other way around
Mike with a bad offensive line and a
talented quarterback and running back
well but nobody dance listeners
limitations are there did you just
chicken in the egg white you oh yeah how
creepy that offers liners and we have
the best if you're a great offensive
line and you're moving everybody being
the theory autologic will be sure to put
anybody back there to run and that's
what the cop was thought and then it
fell to four and 12 and then got got to
knowledge and said oh when maybe we made
a mistake you can't put anybody in back
of a great office a lot it has to match
with office of life and that's what make
you think you le it's not it is not just
stick if they're blocking form it still
has a billion years
Oh Ron ability yeah get his power well
he's great with his ability of picking
up blocks is just incredible where I
mean it's phenomenal what this kid is
doing will tony romo start another game
in dallas in his career that's a great
question man that's a great question and
i would say i would say yes he will
start another game in dallas uh it may
even be maybe even this year you know if
anybody can ever this nickel is so tough
there are two quarterbacks playfully
week one all the way through to the end
of the season so you know you have to
always stay ready but but it's hard if
you're asking me then it's hard to pull
it off put a kid off the field right now
when you're looking at a team that's
eight and one and doing the things he's
doing because what you're getting now
you're getting some you get in you're
getting this trouble and the lessons
come in the struggles you get lessons in
the struggles I don't know which say you
learn more on the things that you fail
in the things that you succeed the
lessons come in a struggle so he gets to
struggle but he still gets the victory
it doesn't come any better than that
bigger win Cowboys in Pittsburgh or the
Seahawks in New England that's a good
one too now that's a great question I
taught that yeah I would say the
Seahawks in New England you know the
tabloids and Pittsburgh was a big win
because that's the best offense that
they played the de Cobo is this cowboy
Tina's face in that atmosphere was as
close to a playoff atmosphere as you
will get any time during this season so
those young guys needed to see that but
fiala born to New England and beating
New England that's huge i didn't think
she ever had the ability to be doing or
like that you know its body today the
deepest to press coverage and and play
the way they played but they proved me
wrong yeah I didn't think they could run
the football like they did I love this
precise kid I we got him we saw the
Notre Dame USC game at Notre Dame and I
he was the quickest guy on the field not
saying a whole lot with us sees talent
out there but you know they loaded him
up let him
oh I thought the offensive line
protected Russell Wilson I love Doug
Baldwin but you know the guy who
fascinates me more than anybody else on
that team Mike kam chancellor kam
chancellor yeah Bradley to link to I I
tell you they I told you that's the only
do that I've ever seen in the NFL it
makes me question my curry you really
working clothes that milk you know it hi
like who did you play against that
questioned your courage you know you
mentioned kam chancellor was anybody you
playin but maybe run a lot you know
running lot when I saw running lot over
there it's what we call grid right 262
that's a slant route I would have to go
to the line of human said man I gotta
run your slip and and I would always
need little Michael to a show cuz it's
big Michaels like new I'm not doing it
your little Michael 63 the run this
little we go back to the jet oh ok now I
run this late I need little Michael to
show up to remind the other you know to
have enough courage to go face the
running lots of the world exit how that
works hey I don't blame you man but kam
chancellor hits people and and it hurts
when he hits people he's just different
at that size that ability he just
changes their defense I love bennett i
think bennett is their best player on
defense but Chancellor is that X Factor
who just seems to take the air out of
people now you know somehow some way
easier to me in literally little effort
yeah when he hits you you're supposed to
feel and hurt hurt when you feel them to
get you in it sound like everything I
did one thing they have it feel like
you're sure there's another thing when
you hear and you sound you hit a pain in
the sound idiot I mean when you go to
Seattle cam he's a big dude got this big
overhead that stands on his big old neck
and he's like man I won't want you to
run into me I mean just phenomenal man I
if you ask me I would love to if I
starting to defend that would be the guy
that would like to start my because I
tell people Mike the head he had on
Edelman in the Super Bowl which and I
give Edelman all the credit the world
because I think he knocked him out he
was on his feet but Edelman held on to
the football it's one of the Lord
just allowed his hits I've ever heard in
a football game and Chancellor just
smashed Edelman and Edelman somehow kept
his feet and gained some yards in the
Super Bowl yeah and that Superboy I
don't know how other men did set because
the Super Bowl before that we smash
cinereus Thomas it was a stock right
there you don't go anywhere else I mean
yo he would hit anybody feel his little
small why God art a big big big black
guy in his mouth he's will knock you out
I mean he comes in and get I I tell you
my dad I'm telling you I Seattle without
him is a different football team but
when he's back there they really are the
Legion of boom one more item here Aaron
Rodgers the finger-pointing or at least
we're getting close to finger pointing
here what do you make of this vocal
Rogers um is this the right tack to tick
wow there's a lot going on in Green Bay
right now who are sworn law degree bed
and and I'm finding out a lot about the
inner workings and of everything over in
green bay III don't know you know as a
quarterback year I watched on Brady last
night talk about that snap that fumble
and any said you know I was going left
my Center thought i was going straight
and you know and somebody said you know
that's on me that's one took in all the
way and I remember watching and thinking
I bet that Center appreciate that do you
know what I mean he is because and when
you're being led by a quarterback like a
Tom Brady who stands up and that was a
crucial situation and you just lost that
game and he stands out he knows when
he's when I quarterback says that was on
me all the stops you can't go anywhere
else with it but if he comes back
talking about the center didn't snap
divided and get it right now that's a
whole nother thing so I myself I like
when the quarterback just shut her down
like that my good to talk to you hope
things are well and uh hopefully get a
chance to talk to you soon BP it's all
well when the cowboys are winning life
and everything Manny did the weather's
better here everybody's smiling as they
dry through the streets it's just good
stuff so it's all great
I'll see it the super bowl all right but
thank you Mike the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience